American taxpayers are financing more
than just weapons what else is going on
with Ukraine these days it's not just
that we are funding the war everyone
knows that we're funding a war which you
might argue if you're funding the war if
you're paying for the war maybe that
means you're in the war but we've never
actually gotten authorization for this
war our leaders leaders keep telling us
that this is the most important thing in
town Mitch McConnell loves this thing
Biden loves this thing there's few
things that bring these people together
more than War well it turns out guys
you're going to be very excited about
this as good tax payers uh it's not just
that we're funding the War uh we're
funding far more than that uh and even
now 60 Minutes is covering it which
tells you this thing might actually be
bursting forth into the mainstream Now
American taxpayers are financing more
than just weapons we discovered the US
government's buying seeds and fertilizer
for Ukrainian
farmers and covering the salaries of
Ukraine's First Responders all 57,000 of
them that includes the team that trains
this rescue dog named joy to comb
through the wreckage of Russian strikes
looking for
survivors and the US also funds the
divers who we saw clearing unexploded
ammunition from the country's rivers to
make them safe again for swimming and
fishing Russia's Invasion shrank
Ukraine's economy by about a third we
were surprised to find that to keep it
afloat the US government is subsidizing
small businesses awesome dudes we're
subsidizing small businesses in Ukraine
sure here if you have a small business
we'll shut you down and you can only go
to big box stores but in Ukraine we'll
fund your little operation man why why
did I do that accent I don't know where
that came
from